so if you were to run earth over a
million times
up to this point
maybe beyond to the end let's run it to
the end
uh what is it how much variety is there
you kind of spoke to this trajectory
that the environment dictates
like chemically i don't know in which
other way
um spiritually
like dictates kind of the direction of
this giant machine that seems uh chaotic
but it does seem to have order in the
steps it's taking
uh how much
how often will life
how often will bacteria emerge how often
will something like humans emerge how
much variety do you think there would be
i think at the level of bacteria
not much variety i think we would get
that's how many times you say you want
to run it a million times
um i would say at least a few hundred
thousand will get bacteria again oh wow
um nice because i i think there's some
level of inevitability that a wet rocky
planet will give rise through
through the same processes
to something very close i i think this
is not something i'd have thought a few
years ago but we're working with a phd
student of mine stuart harrison he's
been thinking about the genetic code and
we've just been publishing on that um
there are patterns that you can discern
in the code or he has discerned in the
code
that if you if you think about them in
terms of we start with co2 and hydrogen
and these are the first steps of
biochemistry you come up with a code
which is very similar to the code that
we see
so it wouldn't surprise me any longer if
we found life on mars and it had a
genetic code that was not very different
to the genetic code that we have here
without it just being transferred across
some inevitability about the whole of
the beginnings of life in my view
that's really promising because if the
basic chemistry
is tightly linked to the
genetic code
that means
we can interact with other life if it
exists
potentially
that's that's really exciting if that's
if that's the case okay but then
bacteria we've got then we've got
bacteria yeah um
how easy is photosynthesis
much harder i would say
you